so we've got two pieces of bad news and
three pieces of good news
how you feeling about the donkey singing
ready
when did the doctor ace it feel really
bad
[Music]
okay believe nation its Santorini day
you blue die Medina but I did that
because I got them inside to this is one
of the main reasons why we came here
Island Santorini Nina has never been so
we gotta take her it was a really rough
night last night oh man
what are the rockiest it's high winds
happening how the rockiest nights I've
ever had
although I didn't need to wear the patch
which for me is crazy cuz they should
get super seasick so the health is
getting better though we both got
allergies or sniffles or something
happening right now
so really rough night I kind of imagined
like I was on the other ride like but
it's pitch black and then you hear cool
oh well then you go up and then anyway
it was chaotic but we made it we're
alive
and we're gonna go to Santorini and sit
on some donkeys with Nina
we are on vote number nine we have to
take tenders to get off this boat we got
to wait our turn this is it the so if
you're waiting for the donkey station
we've been waiting to see Mina on the
donkeys food pestle smoke
we're gonna need Nina's donkey Bertha
Big Bertha
they might say name is too little
together but I think Big Bertha can
handle you
here we go let's go donkey station don't
be super near station how you feeling
about the donkeys
ready nervous
excited we're excited that's a big
donkey for union you should get the
little one all right Nina
have fun don't fall off Gunny they go
the passion you we're passing you the
donkey's come on choke on my destiny now
choking my dust
thank you dust my god loves to go fast
here
Nina is somewhere back there hi Nina
catch up my guide to sense what good
luck my guys taking it down possess oh
this one is my guy too
oh no the one alright it's okay
good donkey listen we all have to take
our time with your business I think
Nina's slowly catching up just wants to
go fast I like it race up the mountain
we're back up front leading the donkey
race oh no we stopped let's go go go
we can't let need to catch up thank you
for the ride buddy thank you for the
ride
much appreciated talk to us don't step
on poo along the way - you need to go up
and not step on any of the poo on the
floor huh okay Nina talk to us I feel
really bad
oh no how come
could you fight for the donkeys ah he is
a nature person all right let's go
explore fear
[Music]
what was the hook so we don't have a lot
of time in Santorini because the crazy
windstorm means we have to leave early
so we're gonna grab an early lunch
around 11:00 and then explore a little
bit go back to the boat it's it a short
day my first lunch spot is closed until
noon but I have a backup I always have a
backup
hopefully we find Yunus more yummy food
[Music]
[Music]
I see it up ahead that blue sign that
they're all blue the blue and pink sign
with the pink Fork
all right made it
Burundi let's go
look at this view up here huh that's a
nice view we're the only ones here you
get the pic for the first ones this one
alright nice this is the table George
Clooney sat at what do you think Nina
you're in George Clooney's table Nina's
got a non-alcoholic mojito and I'm
trying the lazy ass donkey local
Santorini beer exciting there it is
Yama's cheers thank you boom that's good
how's yours try
ollie
it's um the Santorini Brewing Company to
copy hip hoppy kick-ass ales
thanks okay special of the house
Santorini pancakes
this was recommended Santorini pancakes
give it a shot
[Music]
but can you describe it for us
it's different
[Music]
it's electic Wow okay great
all right good that's Nina's description
how's the Oliver all the paste on the
bread is it also authentic alright
all right try it a little take a piece
put it in my mouth is watering it smells
good too
barbecue okay I love a sauce all right
[Music]
nice nice
[Music]
lunch is done what do we think Nina
that's fine satisfied we are at a time
line now though got to get back to the
boat get back to the cabin
probably nap of it yeah yeah feel like
if we don't nap we're gonna get sick
from lack of sleep
probably have a sleepless night ahead -
we both have slight coughs but the nap
will make the difference let's go
donkeys on the way back no donkeys
cable-car cable car
[Music]
[Music]
okay so we've got two pieces of bad news
and three pieces of good news let's say
with the bad what do you got Nina what's
the bad news we're not gonna a since the
weather is really bad it's gotten worse
so it's not safe to get the Athens it's
a bummer because that was the only city
well I haven't been to montenegro guess
we could see Christina which is good but
Athens was like was the thing that made
me super pumped about this trip because
I've never been there and I want to go
but I'm not gonna go we're gonna go to
some other city that have never heard of
that need to start researching and
looking up so we can plan a good day
so Athens is not on the table bad news
number two I'm not feeling very well
didn't sleep we tried to nap and Nina
now they didn't nap I've got a sore
throat and a bit of an ear thing which
if I don't sleep well tonight it could
be really bad news three pieces of good
news coming up
good news number one Evan Carmichael
what's good news I got a guess
okay ask you punch me in the face no
this is a that's the microphone yeah
what do you think yes you can feel now
this good news number one so tomorrow
we're gonna be in this small city with
not a lot to do so I still have to film
I have not done that yet so tomorrow is
gonna be explore the city day we have
it's our first all day in a city because
we've had these kind of crazy times show
in the morning leave in the afternoon
and are shown a afternoon and leave at
night we're here we're supposed to be
there from 8 a.m. to 6 p.m. so we get
the whole thing to see the explore and
then film videos for you guys make some
content the actual good news number 2
was we got to see Santorini that was the
most important one that I went to Nina
to see Santorini Venice both union seeds
but Santorini was like what we centered
it around for Nina and we were the only
boat that got in yes today yesterday no
today
today usually you've got like four or
five six boats in in the port and we
were the only one so all the other boats
canceled so it made sense rainy not as
crazy as usual it turns a population and
getting up and down and all that stuff
but also we got a chance to see it where
nobody else who is scheduled to come
today bit so I'm glad you got to see
Santorini that's a big way I would
rather Nina have seen centuries m.i.c
Hamptons so it's a good trade
too bad news we did too good news for
Dan is one more good news good news my
3s but Carmichael's and we make the best
of everything both smoking a lot of game
actually super I'm very impressed and I
haven't had to take a sea sickness pill
or patch but I'm usually very sensitive
to it but whatever this trip I'm just
telling myself that this is fun we Lena
is not impressed but it's working
friends it's working
maybe I'm gonna take that same approach
to this bug that I kind moose or throw
an amazing we what do you think Nina is
it working
I don't know we'll see gotta get some
sleep tonight but before that dinner
time we're gonna eat some exquisite
meals right Nina
[Music]
all right Nina time to eat up let's see
what you got this Asian
Eurasian Asia meets Asia first time here
at cow's got some lasagna for me what
did you get all right
dig it Nina let's see it we got not bad
all right well that for this for this
cruise that's good dessert time for me
you want a bite
go for it apple strudel with vanilla
sauce and ice cream
that was actually the best dinner this
best dessert that I had on the boat
pretty low bar but how are you feeling
okay and then then we're gonna go
upstairs and look at the buffet yeah as
usual
[Music]
what did you get us a lot all right and
wine
[Music]
drinking too much is bad ladies and
gentlemen so what's the plan for today
zero yeah the good news is it's all
downhill on the way back I'm going to
work on a new book maybe the drama
continues good job